20 matches into the Vancouver Titans
assault on the overwatch league and only
a single team has defeated them they
went 14 Oh across the first two stages
and five one in the playoffs they had a
near-perfect record in their first ever
stage of overwatch league fighting it's
the tide of last year's powerhouses as
he tries to use a self-destruct John who
gets kelex with his self-destruct
instead and Vancouver just rolling over
Foster the Titans frankly these guys
showed up in LA beat everyone's asses
and left an everlasting mark on the
overwatch league stage
[Applause]
was
to the Titans
Stage one champions
but what's truly special about Vancouver
is where they came from were their
journey to the overwatch Leggett began
[Music]
the Titans began as a team of friends
dressed in pink United when it seemed
like the odds were permanently stacked
against them run away is looking like
one of the kind of surprise really good
teams here in the tournament at first
run away was a passion project for
runner a Korean League of Legends
streamer who saw overwatch as his
opportunity to make the jump into
eSports these guys are coming in really
hot they are led by a popular streamer
here in Korea who is also a pretty good
player he paid for everything put his
streaming career on the back burner and
the team began their journey at the apex
league in Korea yeah and their name
runaway does come from runner this
streamer that you're talking about now
he's really dialed back on the streaming
he's very serious about becoming a
professional player here and so
refocused himself put a squad of five
other guys around him and as you say
came off with some impressive wins it
was during this early era of overwatch
that runaway became a fan favorite in
Korea they weren't the best team in the
world hard fought by runaway certainly
looking at proves that luxury walk flew
certainly be the better team overall
tonight they didn't have sacks of cash
or traditionally eSports backing but
they were a tightly knit team that had
chemistry on stage and fans loved them
let's take a look at runaway and of
course runners sitting on top in the
captain's chair it's kind of like the
bridge of a Star Trek ship isn't it I
love it up there yeah
let's drink then mine the odds were
heavily stacked against them they are a
small team funded by one person facing
down the likes of cloud nine fanatic and
envious who would all flock to overwatch
with dollar signs in their eyes they
couldn't just be a fan favourite forever
to really make it to make money they
were gonna have to win and come to
Panthera are they on the homestretch
looks like they may be and that's it
coda Panthera they get the two points
what a heartbreaker for run away after
showing so much prom promise after
having such a fan following for hot
sauce kimchi kind of a lackluster end to
their season and in the following year
of apex they leveled up I can't believe
it run away coming in on paper
oh my such an underdog in the semi-final
if they will win it 3-2 runaways go into
the semi-finals and restarting he is 3 -
ha ha what goes down in this push
probably going to get stalled out Oh 5
better shatter those are gonna get the
net to die in the Kaiser can't they get
it the rest of the way though it's got
him long way to go deep but it's a team
way yeah that is everyone I don't know
the payload moving all they can't quite
get it there again it's so close just
point eight meters away
Hawks all still getting the kill samay
goes down before the eyes like they'll
do it run away goes to the finals what a
story for runaway promotions last season
now in the grand finals taking down LW
blue tears on the faces of run away you
know a team that people counted him out
in the end of the group sages they
counted him out in the quarterfinals
they counted him out today in the semi
finals and they approved that none of
that matters they are going to the APEC
season two grand finals lunatic high
taking on run away the Dark Horse's
versus the uncrowned Kings you couldn't
ask for a better finals lineup
to make this work Hawks on the Reaper
now they better fear Him bumper pushes
back with the whole hog before he goes
down but lunatic high now winning this
fight run away they've got it they take
route 66
very nicely done at the end I think I
finally done it
the uncrowned king Kaiser comes in with
the primal rage to try to turn it around
try to be a hero one last time but
lunatic high is lighting up that kill
feed he's staying alive he's trying to
make it happen but after their loss in
the finals
their role as the little team that could
finally caught up to them sponsorship
opportunities that would help runner
fund the team fell through and their
lack of a team house or any formal team
structure starting to take their toll on
the team chemistry I'm gonna do or nine
Dellavedova Mika motility to the motor
controller son and a misfortune buddy
interest rate treating man - Vanya who
gets angry retirement in midday vamoose
handle Ebola Jenica cooking the moon
sources there they lost no their star
players Kaiser to c9 an organization
that can clearly offer more to young
talent why are they because I was in
Ronald him run away about me getting the
second place in the APEC season - it's
just just me thinking about at least we
got the second place but I only aim for
the first place so that's how I decided
to step down during the cloud nine the
fallout of that season two loss left
them reeling they look like a shell of
their former selves and we're still
broke and sponsor less and run away and
run us up to lunatic high and season two
is always the bridesmaids for now trying
to separate themselves and very
interesting story here given that the
murmurs around run away is that perhaps
our expectations need to be adjusted
just a little bit down run away really
seem to lack cohesion with Kaiser out of
the lineup they were switching tank
members left right and center trying
different identities looking
for something that resembled what they
had in season two and time boy picks up
one God's me another noise might fix
time they're trying to push this one
cord it's three metres until round of
eight matchsticks and they do it the
newbies into season three apex this is
devastating
as you can see that concern run away
will not be going through to the round
of 8 runner had a family now he had a
wife and a kid and that meant he
couldn't put up the kind of financial
support the team needed to get a team
house so he decided to pull out this
band run away and call it quits but it
was his wife flower event who forced
runner to give it one last chance to
give this team his family one last shot
at doing what they set out to do they
banded together and rented a crappy
apartment to Korea players help pay the
rent flower ovens Troost up the place
and fans even donated one fan chipped in
a washing machine awesome
boom comes out in satalia sticky
auto-runners stepped in his coach and
they were gonna give this you need to
see it to believe it cinderella story
one more try and this time the overwatch
League was on the horizon
Blizzard Entertainment is proud to
announce the overwatch League
a global world-class eSport we've
designed from the ground up to celebrate
the best of the best on their path to
victory massive holding groups with fat
wallets are buying into the league and
more than ever
apex was a proving ground for players
who wanted to make it the overwatch
league was the light at the end of the
tunnel for runner flour VIN and the
entire runaway family here the cheers
right there from the runaway fans of
course the season 2 final is still
carrying over their fans up despite
before run in season 3 propelled by the
momentum of this weird eSports family
they'd become by the way made yet
another playoffs appearance in season 4
the royal rotors who want to complete
their journey take home the title vs.
run away our runners-up in season 2 back
to take another crack at the trophy and
a team that is a veteran team of apex
they've been in seasons 1 through 4 not
a single season they were not present so
the story of a team that struggled found
their way in season two were unable to
compete well in season 3 dropping out
early even the group stage season 4 made
their run but once again they were left
heartbroken that is likely gotta be it I
think they might have just done it dizzy
walk this way back here so all on his
lonesome he needs the primal rage he
gets it available he pops it he's
smacking him all the way he has to jump
up in the air he doesn't come down and
done 10 they know what have you done
what an absolute heartbreaker to run
away for tizzy to lose in such a manner
after that year many of their fiercest
competitors moved on for the greener
pastures of the overall shape ladies and
gentlemen introducing the London
Spitfire one
arguably the second-most stacked lineup
behind the Seoul dynasty and their own
they're the only team in the league with
12 active players on their lineup but
run away were left behind
they were unquestionably a great team
who looked great on stage together but
here passed up for other talent they'd
failed to reach their goal they lost
more players and then runner had to
leave the team to serve his mandatory
military service but unlike eSports
teams
families don't quit on each other flower
Ventoux Kover runners role in managing
the team and they banded together to
make their mark on the overwatch league
contenders in Korea that season q
eliminated gets rid of that baby knee
but bumper hair primal rage Plus that
Nana boo she is just ripping through
them over time ticking down and it might
just be an oaf at last tagging just
comes through outside trying to stay
alive trying to stay on top of this
[Applause]
it's the final push guilty and then
they're able to bring it home with a
victory for zero for them on the day and
that's when they showed the overwatch
League what kind of talent they left
behind down there looking for bumper he
doesn't have the primal rage but
something struck friends roar run away
try to take this Shoebill babies out but
day is so low he'll get finished off and
run away I think they might just be able
to do it to close this one out
run away taking a 2-0 Auto eight cents
they're going to the semifinals tomorrow
Goku they got so damn close but in the
end they just cannot do it run away
another cheering moment here in the
booth they're not in the finals yet but
it was a closer series than anyone
could've anticipated and the fifth map
they come up big even stitch rarely
emotional you're getting caught up and
the excitement as Farben runs in one of
his here at the studio I know he's
height back seat he's not allowed of
course to show as himself on camera
because the boat aerials by you know
he's backstage happy at pipe they lost
in the semi-finals in season one of
contenders but in season two they
finally secured the major tournament win
they fought for for so long
Ted both he was going to be eliminated
but we're still in the fight however he
gets war no Jin goes down hope you break
their own two members left alive can
they actually accept this oh my god Tobi
the cake it's gonna plummet and that
just Superman
what do I they finally got it
good third attempt big hit the
championship win we got more defending
don't worry guys we're gonna pop some
more rock put third time out
beep vanish then push themselves over
the finish line they get the victory all
the way tape maps all the way to three
rounds on illios but they finally do it
they did it
apex season two they failed season four
they failed they failed in a pack but a
contender season two in the sixth season
of Korean overwash fans are in tears but
this time for a different reason I mean
the this the feeling of relief that this
one has to be experiencing right now
they come out and they will be able to
for the first time in their careers lift
this trophy as a squad still in tears
something somewhat in shambles just so
elated but they have finally done it
one man's dream turn earlier turned
reality a family of teammates who
wouldn't take no for an answer and then
in October 2018 flower been announced
that runner's dream had finally been
realized she could win the season to LA
no a son Saudi legal Jackie while you do
soccer is Sunita at all
Tom Chiaki while most of the season two
expansion teams cherry picked the best
players from rosters all over the world
but the Vancouver Titans were an
exception they signed the entirety of
the runaway family and in storybook
fashion they made the jump to the
overwatch league together don teabolo
hey hey come over hundred on Tommy get
down a proton donor for Hodgman
which to me is awesome overall top Argos
comes on top through it all they'd
arrived on the biggest stage still
standing together and they showed up
with something to prove
Tony come to be almost you guys are
tuned your cutter - superbunny a solo
leukemia Kentucky Kentucky money
tomorrow sake oh we're not a rake and
when we can sign a nautical token they
call me welcome them to the stage it's
their first time they're here in Los
Angeles the bad Cobra Titans
[Applause]
I'm coming to watch these players stand
on the overwatch league stage dreams of
playing in this league finally they've
got one title under the belt of the
Korea Championship for season two of
contenders but now in the 2019 overwatch
League season they're looking to build a
new storyline start a new chapter as you
mentioned as season two got underway it
became pretty clear that runaway were
ready for the overwatch is right out of
there diggin Koba both say good night
another shot that shot there on the VF
takes the milk and optic gang are in
midair and then style Vancouver Titans
glide into the finish Colorado 4-0
opening debut year in the 2019 overwatch
League season absolutely dominant we saw
so much of what has made this team
strong in Korea already here and at the
rest of the league were no match for the
bond that this band of brothers had
formed
running away anymore that's for sure to
cover Titans coming into the league no
losses yet looking to make it seven a
know today they master the goats
competition bumper quickly became one of
the league's best leaders this is where
popper usually does something crazy to
it
give me the 360 shatter he's coming in
so minsu has proven to be one of the
league's best damage dealers and John in
style Don diva all stage long but to the
primal rage really aggressively trying
to get by and maybe gets done there's a
steel batch there's to kill got too deep
a little bit too quick the grab got work
it out goes down early as he tries to
use the self-destruct John who gets
kelex with his self-destruct instead and
big Hoover just rolling over pasta the
Titans have come to feed and that's
gonna be a 200 lead in style for
Vancouver more than anything though they
played like a well-oiled machine
no growing pains no hiccups the start
line 7 and 0 with the regular stage
zero right nowadays a nine-week straight
they went from left behind in Korea to
best in the world all in just a year
I'm ready to go even such a returns on
its on the Alcazar there's a more stage
what does it be under seventy one
digitizing and in March they made
history by becoming to season two stage
one champions completely undefeated they
lost both
[Applause]
Juventud stand on the precipice
they say that north never forgets
[Applause]
would never be forgotten
what thinking of his best
they will be
we watched all season long as this team
took the league by storm and proved they
were a force to be reckoned with I mean
the shock played Vancouver better than
anyone we've seen all stage was a huge
statement with the Titans they come in
the overwatch League confident champions
back in Korea they come in as an
expansion team newcomers to the
overwatch Lee and take our stage one
they then ran the tables once again in
stage two going undefeated all the way
to the finals where they were bested by
the San Francisco Sean who have proved
to be their greatest adversary this is
the Titans will they lose for the first
time ever in mode for the Vancouver
times they have the Sun barrier to beat
shatter under the cart some ensue knock
down he's taken out soon John Newtown as
well and the shock they may have done it
treating Hawks off just trying to stay
on the point but that's gonna be the
grand from Sinatra comes in and this
shot get done it
thanks to champion
but what we really wanted to show you
today is where that story started in
Korea with runner and flower oven and a
dream and a broken air conditioning unit
and heartbreak and perseverance this is
a sort moment we had an incredible final
and what I was finally able to break the
barriers it took them six seasons to
make the realization of millions of
competitors dreams right in front of you
know corporate funding or fancy team
houses just six friends behind computer
screens dressed in pink with everything
to lose and an unbreakable bond fighting
to do what they love for a living they
may be the vancouver titans now but
nobody will ever forget run away thanks
for watching if you want more content
like this hit the sub button and ring
that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages